Speaker 1: I don't think this will come as
a surprise to many of you. But under Elon
Musk's stewardship, for lack of a better
term, Twitter is no longer enforcing its
COVID misinformation policy. CNN has
an article about this where they write
Twitter said it will no longer enforce its
long standing COVID misinformation policy.
Yet another sign of how Elon Musk plans to
transform the company he bought a month ago.
CNN writes that in 2020, Twitter developed this
set of rules that prohibits or seeks to prohibit,
quote, harmful misinformation about
COVID and the vaccines. And we all know,
as CNN summarizes, that between January of 2020
and September of 2022, Twitter suspended more than
11,000 accounts for breaking COVID misinformation
policy. Twitter is no longer going to do that.
They did not appear to formally announce the
change, but some Twitter users last night spotted
a note added to the page on Twitter's website,
which says Effective November 23, 2022. That's
about a week ago. Twitter is no longer enforcing
the COVID 19 misleading information policy.
They don't explain why, but they simply say it
is no longer being enforced. What is important
to understand here is that this is all part of
a package of changes being brought to Twitter
under the false pretense, the false pretense that
Twitter became over the last couple of years, some
kind of woke left wing disinformation or forced
information or speech policing platform. We know
that's not the case from independent studies done
about messaging on Twitter. But also there were so
many people overtly spreading COVID disinformation
that 11,000 accounts were suspended. Part of what
Elon Musk has been doing is restoring many
of those suspended accounts to their former
glory, I guess they would say. And this is just
part of it. What do I think is ultimately going
to happen with Twitter? I really don't know. There
are some who are sure that Twitter will evaporate
and go away. I just don't think so. I think
there's too many people on the platform. Will
Twitter be weakened by fleeing advertisers and
user abandonment? It's completely plausible. But
there is no question that Twitter is changing.
And people have written to me and they said,
David, I've noticed with tears. They said,
David, I see you're not tweeting as much.
There is something that just makes me not that
interested in participating on the platform. Hey,
nobody. I'm not under the pretense or delusion
that everybody's out there waiting for my tweets.
I'm not making a I'm not making a statement of any
kind. I just see that the engagement quality has
declined. I see that the Twitter blue thing has
also not been particularly exciting, and I'm just
less interested in posting to Twitter. That's
all that's going on where we will be three four
months from now, we will see. But officially
now, COVID disinformation, maybe not welcomed,
but certainly allowed on Twitter. The David Pakman
Show continues to be a community and audience
supported program. We really do depend on your
support. We have something called the membership
program. You can sign up at join Packman dot com.
You get The Daily Show, no commercials in audio
or video formats. You get the Daily Bonus Show.
Remember that thing which Alex Jones really hates.
Speaker 4: On this show where you
want to make money and everybody
else who makes money to fund themselves is.
Speaker 1: Bad. Yeah, very, very bad. And also
invitations to the members only town hall sign
up at join Packman dot com coupon code always
available 24 starts now or please no more Trump
that's another coupon code please no more. Trump